laurent wauquiez re bonsoir
c'est ici ce soir parce que j'avais une
question importante à vous poser
regardez c'est quoi cette position
ça c'est déjà vous a déjà visité des
usines de tourneur de bois voilà ça
ressemble à ça à
saré dit la cravate quand même je suis
d'ailleurs le seul à continuer emporté
alors vous avez été ministre de la
recherche chez vous avez trouvé j'ai je
cherche encore les ministres
des affaires européennes de l'emploi
portant le gouvernement
quatre postes en cinq ans c'est très
suspect où j'avais qu'avec un cv comme
ça personne ne nous engage pas assez il
ya deux options soit je suis génial mais
tout le monde s'en est pas encore aperçu
soyez un petit problème sur les
nominations ouvert de 10 à 6 et ça c'est
pas humain de gc ca
donc aujourd'hui vous êtes vice
président de l'ump député de la
haute-loire et maire du puy-en-velay
mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ça n'a rien donné
et
alors tu sais ce que c'est ça c'est we
are the world repris par patrick
sébastien c'est non j'ai apprécié
l'hommage alors laurent en 2010 est
fondée la droite sociale à la droite
sociale c'est un peu un oxymore comme la
force tranquille quoi j'ai d'agir et les
verts pollueurs ou les communistes
capitalisme et bin jassim je pense qu'en
france on fait plus de social converse
d'échec on achète le silence des gens on
les aide pas repartir et moi ce pourquoi
je plaide ce n'est pas de l'assistanat
c'est l'insertion par le travail c'est
l' équilibre entre les droits et les
devoirs mais je pense que la droite peut
aussi faire du social intelligent le
cancer de l'assistanat c'est vous ça
c'est social ça j'ai dit que
l'expression je le regrettais
puisqu'elle était pas bonne mais que le
fond je le maintiens les racines
chrétiennes de la france et social ça ça
rien à voir c'est juste une évidence
enfin voila c'est notre histoire est un
pays laïc ça veut dire pas de
communautarisme le communautarisme
triomphant c'est social ça oui le
communautarisme triomphant ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire en fait plus personne
ne se respectent plus personne ce
support c'est dans les piscines on
demande des horaires différencier voilà
moi je suis contre ça je pense que la
république est s'est construite sur la
laïcité c'est ce qu'il faut défendre
jean luc je sais que bernard laporte qui
était un ami personnel et je vais dia et
absolue qui est là il me fait c'est un
bon mec
l'abrogation de la loi sur le mariage
gay et lesbien c'est social ça je suis
attaché à l'idée de ce qu'est une
certaine conception de la famille de la
filiation je me suis battu contre cette
loi je trouve assez faux culs d'aller
ensuite expliqué bon ben voilà on
reviendra pas contre c'est mes
convictions mais quand vous draguez
frédéric mitterrand conseil des
ministres alors c'est quoi vous qui
connaissez thierry frédéric mitterrand
ça bien vous savez très bien que si
jamais on doit faire la liste de tous
ses fantasmes va falloir écrire
supplémentaires
c'est comme une histoire enfin on serait
venu
bien frédéric mitterrand qui lui en bois
pourquoi tu me regardes avec cet air
langoureux pourquoi tu me regardent
comme ça
alors qu'aujourd'hui alors est ce que
pourrait parler monsieur qu'est ce que
vous resterez refuse de répondre à ces
questions monsieur c'est les secrets du
conseil des ministres
alors vous dites que vous voulez en
finir avec la droite de papa mais c'est
à pour instaurer la droite de papy
personne ne croit plus les politiques
ouais il ya un problème de la corruption
qui touche une minorité de politique
mais avec quand même des scandales à
répétition donc il ya quand même des
grands coups de nettoyage afin de il ya
le fait que contient des beaux discours
et que les actes ensuite ne suivent pas
et puis je pense on brasse toujours les
mêmes idées depuis une éternité j'essaye
de renouveler tout ça ça veut dire
d'abord plus d'intégrité j'ai refusé par
exemple de toucher la prime d'anciens
ministres quelqu'un qui comme son emploi
le gouvernement lui verse pas une prime
d'anciens un ministre il reçoit une
prime d'anciens ministres monsieur
cahuzac toucher cette prime d'anciens
ministres alors là oui tout en ayant un
compte pas gérée par sa mère
[Applaudissements]
ces fragments alors moi je suis clean
total t'écouter l'euro on va faire une
interview psy je pense vola
laurent wauquiez etes-vous parano parano
comme tout présentateur de télé oui
iso schizo n'en mêmes convictions même
idée julio j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour le final cela et héros et héroïnes
définitivement l'info l'info ça m'arrive
maso non sado maso ni l'un ni l'autre
exhibo exhibo
pas sur un plateau
morano morano j'aime bien made in populo
populo au sens de pascal obispo oui
j'aime bien me voilà est-ce que vous
êtes démago démago non disco disco daft
punk ou
adamo a des mots non gigolo gigolo non
gros lolos
gigot d'agneau vous gigot d'agneau non
moi c'est plutôt le fin gras du volet
vous êtes rocco
siffredi c'est ça qui était si fredo de
porno sérieux non mais
regardez bien youporn dans un an
comme tout le monde comme tout le monde
moi voilà il connaître
net comme toi la dame vend pas là et
ouais vous n'êtes pas tarder au pétard
donnons notre coq ou non coco non non
héros non plus non mais faut demander
michel drucker si ces frappes ces chiens
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu